- Good morning, everyone, I
have really nothing to say,
other than, it's almost inexpressible
how happy this event makes me,
and to see so many familiar
faces gathered together
to discuss Horace Walpole's
"Castle of Otranto,"
and really, in so doing, to, to commit
and bear witness to what
we care so deeply about,
and our shared endeavor,
so I can't tell you
how much I'm looking
forward to this afternoon.
Welcome, and I'm now going
to pass the mic over.
- It is a special occasion,
and I just want to,
since Annie's portrait is behind me,
to honor the founders of
this wonderful resource
The Walpole Library,
Wilmarth and Annie Lewis,
their vision, and their
scholarship really resounds
to this moment, and this
treasure of a place is one
that I've returned to
often, and with gratitude,
and I welcome you to it.
My job today is just to keep the time,
basically, and we're going to be mindful
of 10 minutes for each of the speakers.
I do want to say, though,
by way of preface,
this occasion reminds me
of a program we had here
at the Walpole, which was a followup
to Yale's Tercentennial
Conference on anti-theatricality,
and it was called "The
Country House Weekend,"
and those of us who were involved
in the conference decided not
to do an edited collection,
but rather to meet, a year later,
and talk about what we had
done at the conference,
and what our work
generated since that point.
And out of that came, not just
out of that conference alone,
but gave its inflection to
Felicity Nussbaum's "Rival Queens,"
to Lisa Freeman's book
on anti-theatricality,
to Julie Stone Peters'
"The Theatre of the Book,"
to my work "It" and others that
came out of this opportunity.
So I want to capture some of the spirit,
although I don't know that we'll have 10
or 12 books on "Castle of Otranto."
(group laughs)
Excellent as that would be,
I hope it will be generative
in that way, because it
was the conversation,
it was the sense of the
galvanic intellectual moment
of we, who love the 18th century,
gathered together to
talk about one of its,
one of its works, I hope it will generate
that, the kind of excitement it did
on that previous occasion,
as a matter of fact,
I'm confident it will,
knowing these speakers.
I'm going to introduce each
of the speakers in order,
and then let them take the floor.
First, let me welcome Sandra Macpherson,
Associate Professor of English
at Ohio State University,
author, of course, of "Harm's Way:
"Tragic Responsibility and the Novel Form,"
from Hopkins in 2010, and an
essay of the political fallacy,
which is due out in "PMLA"
next month, I believe, so.
This month, yeah, right,
okay, it's now alert.
(group laughs)
"PMLA" right now, and coming, a book called
"The Shape of Form," next, Jesse Molesworth,
on my left, Associate Professor of English
at Indiana University, and,
of course, you will know him
from "Chance and the
Eighteenth-Century Novel:
"Realism, Probability, and Magic."
At the end of the table there on my left,
Sean Silver is Associate
Professor of Literature
at the University of Michigan,
he is currently working
on a history of complexity,
from its conceptual origins
in the philosophy, crafts, and arts
of 17th century Britain to its emergence
in theories of self-organization
in the mid 19th century.
That's a lot in a
sentence, but I just want
to give a moment of a shout out to a book
that I've been editing with Maggie,
former director here at The Lewis Walpole,
Maggie Powell, on hair
in the 18th century,
and the essay, by Sean,
is related to this work
about hair as product, as master metaphor
for the underlying organization
of intellectual life,
and practical life in the 18th century,
so I'm, I just want to make that note
about the connection there.
Then, of course, Cynthia
Wall, Professor of English
at The University of Virginia, author
of "The Prose of Things: Transformations
"of Description in the Eighteenth Century,"
and "The Literary and
Cultural Spaces of Restoration."
And here, I just want to make a shout out
to the work of Professor Wall,
which has been generative in my own,
I just want to say that publicly,
and put it on the record as
we here, for posterity.
(group laughs)
And then,
Eugenia Zuroski is Associate
Professor of English
and Cultural Studies
at McMaster University,
and editor of the journal
"Eighteenth-Century Fiction,"
she's writing a book about funniness,
and has a lot to say about
Walpole's nautilus cup,
in case you're interested,
and of course we are.
(group laughs)
We insist on your account of that,
as well as your account
of "The Castle of Otranto."
So that is my introduction,
and without further ado,
I turn it over to our speakers.
(overlapping chatter)
- It's me, right?
- It is.
- Okay, thank you so much, Joe,
and thank you to Jonathan, and to Nicole,
and everyone involved in arranging
this extraordinary event,
I'm so moved and honored to
be here among people I respect
so much, many of whose books
and essays I've been
teaching this semester,
so it's an especial treat
to see you in the flesh.
So I'm a bit chagrined to be going first,
since I'm going to be violating the law
that Jonathan set down right off the bat,
which was to be, you know, spontaneous,
which I'm incapable of being.
(group laughs)
So, because I can't think
without writing some stuff,
so here's my recent thoughts
on "The Castle of Otranto."
So I return to "The Castle
of Otranto" in the context
of a graduate seminar I'm
teaching this semester
on description, we began
with theoretical work
in literary criticism and art history
on the descriptive turn, post critique,
surface reading, ekphrasis, still life,
formalism, and we've been
moving, week by week,
through descriptive genres
in modes of writing,
from Cowper's "Tale" to "120 Days of Sodom."
So the question motivating
this endeavor, at least for me,
is what would a descriptive
poetics look like,
not only for our field, but in general.
Would it be a kind of ekphrasis
itself, is it possible
to describe verbal objects
without interpreting them,
can or does literary
criticism practice literal
or surface reading?
It seems to me that, for
the most part, we don't.
Heather Love, for example,
seeks to appropriate,
for our discipline,
forms of close attention
that, because they offer descriptions
of surfaces, operations, and interactions,
bypass, she says, the
metaphysical and humanist concerns
of hermeneutics, but when she turns
to describe a literary text,
Toni Morrison's "Beloved,"
description looks a lot
like interpretation.
Love says she wants to
follow up on a suggestion
by Stanley Crouch, mostly
ignored by later critics,
that Morrison's primary gift is one
of neutral detailed description; quote,
"He cites a passage approvingly
where Sethe makes biscuits,"
she recounts, yet she also insists
that biscuit making is not,
and can never be mere biscuit making,
that instead of providing a background
for the events of the novel,
Morrison's descriptions are
a vehicle for a critique
of historical reclamation.
Indeed, she concludes
that Morrison's account
of dehumanization contrasts
with Goffman's assiduously
neutral portraits
of social interactions,
and with Latour's refusal
of humanist ethics.
And she remains quite
committed to this contrast,
"A turn from interpretation
to description might be a way
"of giving up the ghost of
a hermeneutics of empathy
"and recognition," she reflects,
"but who among us is
willing to exchange the fat
"and the living for
the thin and the dead?"
So I think maybe I'm willing
to make that exchange.
(group laughs)
And I think maybe Walpole is willing,
and perhaps the gothic
is entirely predicated
on this exchange of the fat and the living
for the thin and the dead.
But even this is too substantive a claim
for a rigorously descriptive poetics.
As I said, I'm not sure
what Goffman's assiduous
neutrality would look like
for literary criticism, maybe I will know
by the end of the semester.
For now, I'm simply going to
share with you my experience
of returning to "The Castle of Otranto"
with a different set of questions
and commitments than I had the
last time I read the novel.
Then, I was reading it
for my book, "Harm's Way,"
and I was tracking the logic
of action at a distance
of proximate causation,
of strict liability,
I was interested in how Jerome
and Hippolita are causes
of Matilda's murder, the former
because he creates the sexual jealousy
that sends Manfred after
Theodore and Isabella,
the latter because she
literally dispatches Matilda
to Theodore as an intercessor
on behalf of Manfred.
Had I managed to get my
thoughts together enough
to include "The Castle
of Otranto" in my book,
I might have said something like,
"The Catholic logic of intercession,
"the practice of deputizing
an agent to act on one's own
"or a third party's
behalf is more essential
"to the way the novel
works through the problem
"of responsibility than the idea
"of original sin pointed
to in Walpole's preface."
I would have attended to the centrality
of object agency, thing liability,
and its converse, the instrumentalization,
de-personification of human agents,
and I would have insisted
that strict liability
for the effects of actions,
not in any immediate way
one's own, is the gothic.
I might still say this,
and I guess I actually have just said it,
but in the book I'm completing now,
these are the sorts of
things that interest me.
Although in the preface
to the second edition,
Walpole satirizes a naive mimesis
that would have Rosencrantz
and Guildenstern describe,
or Rosencrantz describe for
Guildenstern the iconography
of the palace of Copenhagen,
"The Castle of Otranto,"
at least, for this reader,
is all about doors,
gates, windows, floors,
chambers, casements, and stairs.
The dominant formal
feature of the novel is
what one might call
chronotropic description,
a tropology of space and movement.
This is not, I think,
equivalent to what Cindy,
via Henry Peacham, calls pragmatographia,
here is no investment in energia,
in vividness of description, rather,
these architectural forms are
what George Kugler would
call "primary objects,"
forms whose functions is
to be undifferentiated,
the same shape always and everywhere.
The importance of these forms,
the way they take up
space, get in the way,
especially of the
unfolding of the incidents
of plot and their meaning is parodied
in the slapstick exchange
between Jaquez and Diego,
who frustrate Manfred's desire to know
what they have seen by
discoursing at large
on how doors open and
shut, and it's that great,
you know, clown moment.
Later, this parody is
ratcheted up in the procession
of the stranger knight and his train,
which is a cavalcade of
nothing so much as metonymy,
two trumpets, 100 foot
guards, as many horse,
each phrase an example of the indexing
of an object, in this
case, a human person,
by her attributes.
Manfred, for his part, is a
parvenu of suspicious reading,
coming upon Conrad's body
mangled beneath the helmet,
he's entirely indifferent
to the banal facticity
of the corpse, preferring, instead,
to focus attention on
the object that calls out
to be read allegorically, or
emblematically, the helmet.
Hippolita, on the other
hand, is indifferent
to anything but the death
of her son, we're told.
So at the very outset,
Walpole stages an opposition
between literal and hermeneutic attention,
and indeed, one could say
that the novel is a fantasia
of literalization, and in particular,
a literalizing of verbal artifacts,
a kind of reverse ekphrasis of the clause,
grown too large to inhabit.
This is one way to
understand the other thing
that is currently obsessing
me, which is the sheer number
of exclamation points and em dashes
in the orthography and
typography of the text.
This, too, is literalization, we're told
that Manfred is brought to his senses
to register Conrad's demise
by a folly of ejaculations,
and what is "The Castle of Otranto"
but such a folly of ejaculation?
The novel is built upon
intensifying scenes
of exclamatory and interrogative speech,
and the two practices
of literalization are brought together,
literalizing in objects, lexical units,
and literalizing the content
of the, the affective content
of lexical units in punctuation
are brought together
as the novel unfolds,
especially in the scene
between Manfred and the sighing knight,
where the former's ejaculations
register speech on the part
of the knight that, as a
narratologist might say,
is disnarrated, pointed
to, but not represented,
a deixis, an act of pointing
that points to, instead,
bodily morphology, the shake of the head
that is the identical
characteristic movement
of the helmet's plumes.
So this is about as far as I've managed
to get in my thinking,
someone else might want
to say something substantive
about fragmentation,
interruption, the link
between these formal features,
and the thematics of
usurpation, but in conclusion,
I just want to point
to Bianca's description
of the gigantic, animated statue.
"It," she says, "as big, as big, dash."
A failed simile that, in
eschewing indexicality,
prevents reading, a deixis that points
to the attributes of a
thing, without explaining it.
This, in a very literal sense,
is what "The Castle of Otranto," for me,
is about, if "aboutness"
is the right word.
(group applauds)
- Jesse.
- Thanks to everyone, this is a,
you know, been a fabulous
event, and thank you for coming.
So this paper is an extension
of an article I wrote
on Walpole several years ago,
called "Gothic Time, Sacred Time,"
and in that essay, I argued
that there is such a thing
as the gothic clock trope, that is to say
that in the gothic time is
not really out of joint,
as someone like Derrida argues, rather,
it's both out of joint,
but also aggressively
what I call "in joint," that is to say
that there's a precision to
the timing of the actions
of events in the gothic,
and especially an interest
in the hour of their occurrence,
and maybe the emblem for that
might be the bleeding nun
in "The Monk," who appears
on the 5th of May,
every fifth year, as soon
as the clock strikes 1:00.
So the point that I made in this essay was
that this phenomenon seems rooted
in a very odd decision to me,
and that is Walpole's decision
to write a novel that
obeys the unity of time.
That is to say that, you know,
we know that this plot unfolds over a,
you know, roughly, evenly
spaced period of three days,
it's in the same location,
so it also obeys the unity
of space, during these three days,
the passage of time is regularly marked,
not really by the number of the hour,
but by natural signifiers,
sunrise, sunset,
but also by supernatural
signifiers, as well,
so that, you know, the
appearance of the helmet,
the foot, the sword,
the arm of Alfonso seem
to operate like ticks in some type
of clock that is gradually winding.
In any case, there's a, you
know, a clock-like treatment
of time in "The Castle of Otranto."
I mean, it's always been shocking,
shockingly odd to me, the
interest in the unity of time,
and you might say, well, it
creates the dramatic structure
of the novel, in the sense
that the five chapters feel
like the five acts of a play, and,
you know, maybe it enhances
the Shakespearean character
of the novel, but we
also have to remember,
of course, that Shakespeare is, you know,
famous ultimately for denying the unities,
and so there's something, you know,
I think also profoundly un-Shakespearean
about that decision.
So, in any case, since I wrote that essay,
which was on Walpole,
and Lewis, and Radcliffe,
I've become interested in kind
of tracking this gothic clock
trope into subsequent fictions
that have been influenced by the gothic,
so "Wuthering Heights," "Great Expectations,"
and the rest of this paper's
actually on "Mrs. Dalloway."
(group laughs)
Which is a novel that,
you know, I think is,
you know, increasingly seen
within the gothic tradition,
particularly following
Paul Saint Amour's book.
Virginia Woolf's novel, "Mrs.
Dalloway," features an array
of clocks, meticulously
marking the passage
of time over the course of
a single June day, 1923.
The Westminster neighborhood in
which the novel's primarily set,
two clocks joust with
one another for primacy.
There is, of course, the masculine figure
of Big Ben, whose ringing is heard
on five separate occasions,
and there is St. Margaret's,
the church whose bells are personified
as the feminine counterpart to Big Ben,
so this is from the novel.
"Ah, said St. Margaret's,
like the hostess who comes
"into her drawing room on
the very stroke of the hour,
"and finds her guests there
already, I am not late."
Big Ben and St. Margaret's, therefore,
express themselves as versions of Richard
and Clarissa Dalloway,
the married couple whose story
forms the core of the novel.
Set to ring two minutes after Big Ben,
St. Margaret's seems
scarcely more than an echo
of its more prominent competitor,
much in the way that
Clarissa now devotes much
of her own life to supporting the work
and professional life of her
husband, a conservative MP.
The setup is therefore not
unlike that found in "The Monk,"
in which the masculine monastery bell
and the feminine convent bell joust
with one another, sending the students,
or the citizens of Lewis' Madrid
to perform tasks at their appointed hour.
"Mrs. Dalloway," it is Big Ben, for example,
that informs us that the
time is the early morning,
during the novel's opening
scene, 10 o'clock, seemingly,
when Clarissa sets off to buy flowers
for the party she is
scheduled to host later.
"So there, out it boomed,
first a warning musical,
"than the hour, irrevocable,
the leaden circles dissolved
"in the air," in its four
subsequent appearances,
Big Ben marks the time very
carefully as 11:30 a.m.,
noon, 3:00 p.m., and 3:30 p.m.
The effect, therefore, is
partially to instill a sense
of time discipline on a novel that lurches
through various memories
across vast stretches of time,
more insistently, though,
Big Ben's carefully
marked ringings bear
out the formal oddness
that the novel happens to share
with "The Castle of Otranto,"
it also obeys Aristotle's
unity of time, and in fact,
you might say that this is one
of the very few novels written
since "The Castle of Otranto"
that obeys the unity of time.
"Mrs. Dalloway," of course,
features no actual ghosts,
but it does feature an array
of characters who are haunted
in various ways, according
to the logic suggested
by Terry Castle, where the
mind has become a world
of phantoms, consider the
case of Septimus Warren Smith,
the poet and soldier whose story
of shellshocked trauma
intersects with the main plot.
Between these two roles, poet and soldier,
critics have had much
to say about the latter,
and little to say about the former.
This imbalance is unfortunate,
first because the poet's love
of words expresses itself strongly
throughout Septimus' internal monologues,
and second, because
words frequently trigger
Septimus' traumatic flashbacks
to his life as a soldier,
and one of these words happens to be time.
So this is from the novel,
"'It is time,' said Rezia,
"the word time split its husk,
poured its riches over him,
"and from his lips fell like shells,
"like shavings from a plane,
without making them hard,
"white, imperishable words, and flew
"to attach themselves to their place
"in an ode to time, an
immortal ode to time.
"He sang, Evans sang among the orchids,
"there they waited for the
war, til the war was over,
"and now the dead, now Evans himself.
"'For God's sake, don't
come,' Septimus cried out,
"for he could not look upon the dead."
Under his command as poet,
the word "time" was once
an ally attached to his
most ambitious poem,
"An Immortal Ode to Time," here, though,
it has become his enemy,
attached to both the memory
of his dead friend, Evans,
whose spirit haunts Septimus
throughout the novel, and
to the unwelcome suggestion
from his wife, that his psychiatrist,
Dr. Bradshaw, is expecting them soon.
In fact, in the hands of Dr. Bradshaw,
time has become something else entirely.
Whereas for the poet, Septimus,
it is an abundant resource,
something that pours its riches over him,
for the psychiatrist, Bradshaw,
it is a scarce commodity,
something to be managed and rationed.
To his patients, he gave
three quarters of an hour.
Woolf's personification of
Big Ben as a masculine source
of authority, therefore reaches its zenith
in its presentation of
Bradshaw, the psychiatrist.
In the mind of someone
who worships proportion,
divine proportion, Big Ben might be seen
as its earthly minister,
carving hours proportionally
into quarters, and coaching its subjects
on the practice of
efficient time management.
Eventually, of course,
Septimus' dementia will
transform Bradshaw,
along with Holmes, the
physician, into minions
of a Lucifarian brute with red nostrils,
but the novel itself has already hinted
at Bradshaw's status as gothic tormentor,
so this is from the novel, last passage,
"It was precisely 12
o'clock, 12:00 by Big Ben,
"whose stroke was wafted
over the norther part
"of London, blent with
that of the other clocks,
"mixed with a thin, ethereal way,
"with the clouds and wisps of smokes,
"and died up there among the seagulls,
"12:00 was the hour of their appointment."
So in the chapter that I
focus on in this novel,
this is actually the third appointment
that takes place on the stroke of 12:00,
the first is from "The Monk"
between the Great Mogul
and Don Raymond; the second
is Catherine Moreland's
frustrated appointment
with Eleanor Tilney.
You know, there seems to be some type
of dialogue here, because, for me,
in such passages, the novel
translates the gothic villain
into tormenting psychiatrist.
Likewise, Bradshaw's goddess, proportion,
emerges as a cruel, uncompromising deity,
uncannily inflicting her own form
of psychological torment
within E.P. Thompson's culture
of time discipline.
Septimus' final scene
finds him hiding away
in the second story bedroom of
the Smiths' Bloomsbury house,
panic stricken at the sudden arrival
of the physician, Holmes,
who has been transformed,
in his mind, into
Bradshaw's co-conspirator.
Thus, the novel manipulates a familiar set
of gothic coordinates,
ultimately forcing Septimus
into the role of gothic heroine,
there is also the
Radcliffian tone of dread,
Holmes was coming up the stairs,
Holmes would burst open the door,
Holmes would say, "In a funk, eh?"
Then there is the gruesome
outcome of the scene,
as Septimus commits
suicide by hurling himself
from the second story window, and finally,
there is the clock, as well,
whose ringing interrupts
Rezia's scattered events,
or reflections on the event.
"The clock was striking one, two, three,
"how sensible the sound was, compared
"with the thumping and
whispering, like Septimus himself.
"She was falling asleep, but
the clock went on striking,
"four, five, six."
Here the clock offers
order, and perhaps comfort
within a scene consumed by chaos,
but the irony is that this clock,
along with the numerous
others seen within the novel,
contributes to the set of gothic forces
that precipitate this chaos. Thank you.
(group applauds)
- Thank you, Jesse. Sean?
- Well, thanks, Jonathan, and thanks,
all of you, for being here.
I think I may honesty say
that apart from anywhere that
my wife and daughter are,
there's no place that I'd rather be
than The Lewis Walpole Library.
I intend my remarks to
bear on what it means
to take the gothic seriously,
and I mean the gothic
to refer primarily to the architectural
and aesthetic category, rather
than a strictly literary
or narrative one, though I hope some
of the connections will
emerge over the course
of my remarks.
Too often, we fall into a trap
that Walpole has laid for us,
that is, of thinking that his lightness
of style authorizes a
lightness of approach,
whereas taking the gothic
seriously means treating it
as a sustained, aesthetic response
to mainstream enlightenment style,
including the neoclassical aesthetic
in arts and architecture.
I mean to claim for the gothic
its status as a precursor
and proving ground for complexity,
which I understand is
the categorical claim
that common notions or observed phenomena
are the emergent effects of relationships
between components that
normally remain invisible.
It's a distinction that's important
in cognitive philosophy,
among other places,
and that's where I'm going to start.
So if you were to ask someone 20 years ago
to sketch out how we think,
you might have seen something like,
I, myself, am blocking it.
(group laughs)
- That's how we think?
- I guess, I suppose that's true, yeah.
Yeah.
This is a so-called
functionalist architecture,
I'm going to put some
pressure on that architecture,
thinking imagined as a
series of components,
sensory input is transformed
into internal representations,
which are processed, looped, stored,
transformed, converted into
motor, or proprioceptive output.
It's based on this scheme,
this is the so-called Neumann architecture
from John von Neumann,
who at MIT, in the 1940s
and '50s provided the basic structure
for the modern microcomputer,
that's a machine
that stores and transforms
representations,
it has long-term memory,
short-term memory, and so on.
The crucial, the crucial point is
that thinking is imagined as a system
of discrete, stacked components,
and this is a principle
that runs all the way down,
for it's also, for a system
like this is also imagined
to act on discrete,
accumulated components,
as the accumulator here, I
think, makes abundantly clear.
And that's what we, in
cognitive theory now,
what we tend to call "short-term
memory," that accumulator.
Alright, if you're like
me, you can't see this
without thinking of something like this.
This is Chiswick House, which I choose
because Walpole found it to be exemplary
of neoclassical architecture,
he saw it some time around 1748, 1750.
Or perhaps the, this is
the Inigo Jones Gate,
which is also on the
grounds of Chiswick House.
It's built, like the Neumann architecture,
it's built on a principle
of stacked components,
right, it's a design realized in stone,
its basic operative principle
is the lintel stacked
on columns, or blocks stacked on blocks,
architecture as the stacking of things.
And I'm leaning on this
metaphor a little bit,
I'm also leaning, I suppose,
on the particular magnification
that images make possible,
I think I have 12 images,
which I mean to stand for 12,000 words.
But the links have to do with the kinds
of models we'll accept, or the way
that we understand things to work.
So if you were to ask someone now
what to sketch out a process of thinking,
you might see something like this,
this is a connectionist architecture,
or something like this,
this is a simulation
of a connectionist model
that I put together myself
on Simbrain 3.0, which
is a java-based applet,
which simulates connectionist
neural architectures
on a formalist
microcomputer, and if you're,
also if you're like me, and
I realize, at this point,
I may be the only person
in the room that's like me.
(group laughs)
You can't think of this without thinking
of something like this, right,
this is King's College Chapel,
and it's an example of the gothic,
or this, which is its ceiling,
and it's also the place
that Walpole claimed he first
lost his heart to the gothic.
There was a tradition
repeated by Walpole himself
that Christopher Wren
would regularly tour,
regularly tour the chapel,
suggesting that he'd be happy
to build a replica, if anyone could
but show him where to lay the first stone.
The joke's on a misunderstanding
of the construction
principles of the gothic,
which is not about the stacking of things,
but it's about lines of force.
Its fundamental principle is the rib,
it's a relationship that
sustains a soaring space.
This, by the way, is Walpole's homage
to the King's Chapel ceiling.
This is the, the fan vault ceiling
in the gallery at Strawberry Hill.
And the crucial thing, and this is one
of the transformational moments
in my own intellectual
career as a line spoken
in an offhand way by Joe
Roach in a dingy room at UCLA,
"No persons, or no people,
but only relationships,"
which I'm extending here, no objects,
but only relationships, no ideas,
no thoughts, but only relationships.
That, no stones here to be stacked,
but only connections, not stacking,
but weaving, the emergence of something
where there was nothing before.
In general, connectionists
align themselves,
connectionists align themselves
with a recent turn in the
the sciences towards complexity,
and they trace it back about 50 years,
to developments, especially
with increased computing power
in the 1960s, '70s, and
'80s, but I'm suggesting,
complexity has shadowed
enlightenment reductionism
all along, it's just that we
don't take these alternatives
as seriously as intellectual exercises.
I'm going to wrap up,
or I'm going to sum up,
I suppose, with three provocations,
three, because three is the minimal number
that it takes to create
a complex structure.
Walpole himself saw the gothic
as the major alternative
to neoclassicism, from
the stately rational order
of what he called "the Grecian," or we,
the national, the neoclassical, he opposed
what he called "the
liberty of the gothic."
And while most of us
would be likely to think
of the origins of
architecture as a history
of the stacking of stones,
Walpole himself was quite clear,
the first architectural
gesture was the weaving
of branches to form a roof, right, woven,
rather than stacked,
and I see that repeated
in the fan vault ceiling.
He has, in other words,
flipped the paradigm,
it's relationships are prior to objects.
Two, it's about ornament,
right, it's a part
of the legacy of the
Enlightenment to fetishize forms
which seems to follow functions,
the evidently minimalist stacked forms
of the neoclassical aesthetic would seem
to fit this criterion, but a better way
to think about form is as
the outward manifestation
of design principles, right,
aesthetics as a signal
of the way we imagine
things to be put together.
In this light, it's certainly significant
that buildings like Chiswick House,
or the Inigo Jones Gate,
here,
are brick that are then covered in stucco,
which is tooled to look like blocks,
which makes its principles manifest
in precisely the same
way that Walpole did,
whose gothic ornamentation
was historically,
and I think unfairly been lambasted
for being made out of papier-mache,
as somehow too ornamental,
or perhaps not gothic enough.
And also, in this light,
I think it's important
that repeatedly we see
Strawberry Hill framed
by these kind of vegetable arches.
My final point, I've
been arguing all along
that functionalism, like the neoclassical,
implies certain habits of thought.
The neoclassical edifice
is designed, it's held as
an internal representation
before being realized in stone,
indeed, a representation often developed
by one man, Christopher
Wren, for instance.
This is why it's often
associated with reason,
but the gothic can have
no prior representation,
it's surely significant that
each major gothic revival was
a collaborative effort, John Ruskin,
in a famously vexed love triangle
in the Scottish highlands,
William Morris in a circle
of students at Oxford,
and, of course, Horace Walpole,
and the Committee of
Taste at Strawberry Hill.
The gothic, in other
words, as a negotiation,
nobody designed Canterbury Cathedral,
it evolved in partnerships
between generations
of architects, builders, and craftsmen,
and this is why the style appealed
to Ruskin as a political program,
and it's why it appealed to
Walpole as an aesthetic one,
because it registers a design principle,
which is relational, which is, to say,
connectionist, through and through.
The connectionist school
is part of a recent turn
to complexity, and the sciences
generally pitches itself
as a radical alternative to the legacy
of Enlightenment reductionism,
an alternative roughly 40 or 50 years old.
But as I've been suggesting,
complexity has existed
alongside functionalist
explanations all along,
it's only that until we're willing
to accept ornament as essential,
rather than superficial,
we're unlikely to see the
gothic as anything other
than a self-indulgent
aesthetic experiment.
Put differently,
establishing an alternative
to the burden of Enlightenment,
the burden of the Enlightenment
in modern thought begins,
I'm suggesting, by taking the gothic
at least as seriously as
we take the neoclassical,
including architectural projects,
like Chiswick House, but also
the functionalist paradigm
to which it gives rise.
(group applauds)
- Thank you, Sean. Cindy?
- I have a handout that
actually involved cutting,
and scotch tape, and magic markers,
kind of a different take,
I, too, want to thank our hosts here
for what Joe has called
"a Country House weekend,"
and I'm going to begin with
a well-known Walpole's dream,
which is quoted in two parts.
The genesis of Otranto,
of course, as we all know,
is when, as Walpole says,
"I waked one morning
"in the beginning of
last June from a dream
"of which all I could recover
was that I had thought myself
"in an ancient castle,
a very natural dream
"for a head, filled like
mine, with gothic story,
"and that on the uppermost banister
"of a great staircase, I saw
a gigantic hand in armor.
"In the evening, I sat
down and began to write,
"without knowing, in the least,
"what I intended to say or relate.
"Work grew on my hands,
and I grew fond of it,
"add that I was very glad
to think of anything rather
"than politics," huzzah
for the Walpolapalooza.
(group laughs)
I have to say that when
Jonathan informed us
that this would be videoed, recorded,
I said, "Thank you very much, Jonathan,"
and then I promptly had a dream myself,
in which, we were all
gathered here in sort of pews,
and Jonathan was walking among us
in 18th century waistcoats, and he said,
"Right, we will proceed in order,
"alphabetically, by costume."
(group laughs)
And this being my dream,
of course I had no costume.
(group laughs)
So, but I'll get to the second part
of Walpole's quotation in a minute.
My comments today, come, actually come out
of my classroom experience this semester
in reading "Otranto," I'm
teaching a first year course
on the art of reading and writing,
and it has a gothic theme,
from the 18th century
to the 20th, from "Castle of Otranto"
to "The Haunting of Hill
House" and Stephen King.
And so we started with "Otranto," and I had,
the required edition was
Lewis' "Oxford World's Classics"
with Cleary's notes and introduction.
And I was having the students
read things out loud,
assigning them different characters,
and it didn't go very smoothly,
because they kind of kept
tripping over each other,
landing in each other's dialogue space.
And then they complained,
"But there aren't any quotation marks,"
although, then some people said,
"Mine has quotation marks,"
and someone else said,
"Well, mine does," so we
started comparing editions,
and we talked about the
history of quotation marks
for a little bit, and how, in the middle
of the 18th century,
people often used dashes
to indicate the next speaker,
although Walpole isn't very
consistent in that, either.
And then I started
thinking, I started kind
of paying attention to
the sentences again,
and this comes out of my book
that's coming out this spring,
includes a lot of
attention to the typography
of the page, and the texture of prose.
So lots of typographical
interest going on here,
as well as history of
prose rhythms and things,
general landscape of text,
as well as landscape of land.
And it struck me that in a, at first,
it seemed fanciful, but
then I started following it
through, Walpole's syntax
is, itself, gothic.
The sentences follow their
own weird little corridors,
you turn a corner, and you
bump into something else,
you have to look back over your shoulder
to see who was talking, so I decided to,
you know, work through this.
You know, of course we could say,
along with our dear Mr. Lewis, who said,
"I marvel how such a lucid
and entertaining writer
"as Horace Walpole could have written
"so confused and clumsy a book."
(group laughs)
But I will work with Sean here and go
for the importance of design, the effect,
for me, of "Otranto," has
always been the effect
of design in different ways,
and the more you push it,
the more it hangs together, and,
of course, Lewis himself was,
described some of the works
that came out of the press,
his Strawberry Hill Press, of,
"guilty of the beautiful
negligence of a gentleman,"
but he was also
not very convincingly self-deprecatory,
and certainly in his
sixth edition of "Otranto,"
printed by Bodoni and Parma,
he had so many corrections
that it delayed the publication.
So he is, was a man of detail.
So the rest of that quotation,
"In short, I was so
engrossed with my tale,
"which I completed in
less than two months,
"that one evening I wrote from
the time I had drunk my tea,
"about six o'clock, til
half an hour after 1:00
"in the morning, when my hand
and fingers were so weary
"that I could not hold the
pen to finish the sentence,
"but left Matilda and Isabella talking
"in the middle of a paragraph."
So my remarks today
are looking at the ends
of sentences, and the
middles of paragraphs.
Cleary's note to the
epigraph of "Otranto" tells us
that Walpole reverses the meaning,
to say that, "Nevertheless,
head and foot are assigned
"to a single shape," I
think the sentences in,
Walpole's syntactics were
in that shape, as well.
So, with the handout.
The blue marks my looking
at the ends of sentences.
In the very first sentence, the
very first two sentences end
with Matilda, and, of
course, she ends up being
the prominent one, in so many ways,
and that particular syntax,
we might say that the
dispositionally challenged Conrad
is syntactically obliterated
in those two sentences.
The one on, the bottom of the paragraph,
on the top of page 25, so
the upper right hand corner,
left her in total
darkness, one of the first,
you know, gothic moves of
cliffhanging paragraphs,
inventing the tropes as we go along.
On the flip side, you know, the events,
charging in, "It is my
child, my Theodore."
Lewis himself, again, in another work,
trying to figure out
the appeal of "Otranto,"
he said, "It must be because
something is always happening,
"the end of every dialogue
ends in an explosion,"
well, the end of every paragraph,
and in some ways, the
end of every sentence,
ends up in something
happening one way or another.
The, the passage
with Matilda sinking,
it's Manfred gliding
to the death of his daughter,
and then the last sentence
of the book is just,
not so much an explosion,
but this limp thing we're left with,
sort of the anti-explosion.
But more interesting, to me, well, okay,
the orange is other interesting things
that happened syntactically in here.
41 through 43 is one of those places
where the gothic starts
making its own textual,
subterranean spaces, so
Manfred disappears for awhile,
and comes back, and this
is elaborated beautifully
in "The Monk" and "Mysteries of Udolpho."
And then gliding softly
between another sense
of sort of form and content,
there's a gliding going
on in the paragraph.
But most interesting
to me is those moments
where one person's speaking lands
in another person's territory,
and that's kind of, it
struck me like Sedgwick
on identity and surface,
where personal identity
in the gothic is at no
moment inherent in one,
but applicable is applied
only from outside,
après coup, and by a process
of visual, a simulation,
or seeing as, and in "Otranto," your eye has
to be pretty quick and skilled,
you have to kind of be familiar
with the text, and the passages,
or the passageways of the prose
in order to navigate the turns
and assimilate the identities.
Look on the bottom of the front page,
on the left hand side is that
scene alluded to earlier,
Jaquez, and Diego, and Manfred all,
the babble is syntactically reproduced,
it's a mess, on the right hand side,
facing it, is Henry Morley's 1886 edition,
which is an example of
beautiful Victorian engineering.
(group laughs)
Everybody's identity is
carefully sorted out,
not just by quotation
marks, but in paragraphs,
we make no mistake, whereas
in the Walpole itself,
we make the mistake all the time,
it's kind of the opposite
of the primary objects
in the text, the identities
of the characters are,
you know, slide between each other,
and through the sentences,
so the game I was playing
with myself, and then with my students,
the yellow doesn't come
here through so much,
but it's a, it's a kind
of linguistic game.
"I fear no bad angel, and
have offended no good one,"
and then that territory, you
know, he could be saying,
"Your behavior has been
so gracious to me,"
or, you know, but it's not, is above your seeming
well, somewhere we know that's not
Theodore's speaking,
it's going to be Manfred,
and then it says,
left-hand side, on the second page,
"They seem to inquire, in
the eyes of their Lord,
"what they ought to feel,
surprise, doubt, tenderness,
"respect, succeed each
other in the countenance
"of the youth," oops,
"depart, it cannot be known
"that I assisted thy flight,
swear by the saints above."
Well, no, Matilda isn't
going to be swearing, okay?
"Ah, rest assured that no
suspicion can alight on me,"
she says, "give me thy beauteous hand."
No, Matilda's not going to be asking
for anyone's beauteous hand.
"There is not a sentiment
engraven in my heart
"that does not venerate you and yours,
"the grace and generosity you've
exhibited to your people."
No, "the grace and fervor with
which Theodore uttered this,"
see, all of these not marked by dashes.
"What deed of Manfred authorizes you
"to treat him as a murderer and assassin,
"thou virtuous, gentle maiden," I think,
"have you such thoughts,
"Manfred will never permit our union."
And then it might be,
whoever's responding,
"No, I shall take care of everything,
"oh, thou of the beauteous
hand," no, it's Manfred.
And then I guess I just want to end
with the idea that in the middle
of that last paragraph that
ends with the limp Theodore,
we've got Isabella and
his dear Matilda mixed
in the middle of the paragraph,
so that's my gothic excursion.
(group applauds)
- Thank you, Cindy. Eugenia?
- So, like Sean,
I have been thinking a lot lately
about what it would mean to
take Walpole's gothic seriously,
but I've been thinking specifically
about what it would mean to take Walpole's
and "The Castle of Otranto's"
funniness seriously,
which means I've really
been thinking about
what it would mean to take the novels,
or the novellas' refusal
to take certain things
seriously, seriously.
(group laughs)
And that's what my, my
talk today is about.
I was, started on this path of thought
by reading Cindy's section
on "The Castle of Otranto"
in "The Prose of Things," which
is such a marvelous reading
of this novel, and so I'm, it's both fun
to be able to do this right
after Cindy has presented,
and maybe a little bit embarrassing,
but my paper is also kind of a love letter
to your section on "Otranto,"
in that book, so thank you very much.
So my talk begins with a narrative
of the haphazard beginnings
of my current project
on funniness, which was
routed in various ways
through Walpole, and "The
Castle of Otranto" at its start,
and I was enabled in
this kind of odd start
to a book on funniness by
reading Cindy's amazing section
on "Otranto" in "The Prose of Things,"
which reads "Otranto" as a
kind of Swiftian satire
of the disproportionate significance
of objects in modern life,
whose comedy is premised
on things literally being
thrown out of proportion, right?
Giant helmet is probably
the foremost example.
Cindy's reading confirmed
what I'd always felt,
that "Otranto" was a deeply funny book,
and not just by accident,
or maybe by accident,
but not just as a kind
of effect of failing
to be funny, I mean, failing to be scary.
I was distracted with
how funny the helmet is,
in particular, with its constantly waving
proportionable quantity
of black feathers, right,
which Cindy calls, at one point,
the feathers "less
inherently dignified objects
"than helmets and swords," which means
that a lot of this project
has been me thinking
about the relative
dignity of different kinds
of objects.
(group laughs)
A funniness only compounded
by the image of it,
the helmet, having squashed Conrad,
the feathers waving
ominously over the bleeding,
mangled remains, and
maybe, to a lesser extent,
by the image of Theodore,
trapped under the helmet.
So thinking about the helmet in relation
to these bodies that kind
of get positioned around it,
I started to ask research questions.
Why is this helmet so funny,
why does it get funnier
in proximity to death, is it
because I'm a horrible person?
(group laughs)
Or is it doing something,
is it doing something?
I spent a lot of time
thinking about the tableau
of the scene of Conrad's death,
with the same engrossment
with which Manfred,
of course, views the
single, overwhelming detail
of the helmet, right, so he's, you know,
he's transfixed by this helmet,
and I spent a lot of time just
trying to imagine the scene
of Manfred looking at the
helmet, and the feathers waving,
and the bleeding, mangled remains kind of,
you know, doing whatever they do, messily.
The moment began to strike me, the moment
of Conrad's death, as a very funny parody
of still life, a scene
of life suddenly stilled,
one life because it is crushed,
and one because it is transfixed,
and the constantly
agitated feathers seemed,
in a kind of double metonymic movement
to appropriate the life
that had been taken
from the two human
figures in this tableau,
and transfer that life, inappropriately,
to the helmet, which remains animated
throughout the tale, so
I began to think a lot
about feathers, this is the very beginning
of a research project,
so just remember this.
I began to think a lot about feathers,
about dead things,
particularly dead birds,
which is where feather come from,
whether they're funny
or not, not in reality,
of course, 'cause that would be horrible,
but in representation.
And right around this time I received,
fortuitously, both a sabbatical,
and a sizeable research grant
from the Canadian government.
Thank you, SSHRC, so in pursuit
of the secrets to why things are funny,
I went to Europe armed with a
copy of "The Castle of Otranto,"
and spent three solid
weeks looking at paintings
of dead animals, that was the
beginning of this project.
I also went to the newly
renovated Strawberry Hill
for the first time, and
that was pretty incredible.
I was very distracted by my mission
to understand the image of dead animals,
dead creatures, and birds, in particular,
so I took a photograph of every
single bird I came across,
in like the ornamentation
of Strawberry Hill,
and I was surprised to
find there a lot of them.
I also thought a lot about hybrid objects,
or what I, I sometimes think
of as confused objects,
I mean, confused is a
term that the novel uses,
and I love the quotation from Lewis
that describes the tale as,
as "clumsy and confused."
I come back to clumsiness,
kind of towards the end here.
But confused objects combining,
like the giant helmet,
creaturely detritus,
and man-made materials,
and that is how I became
interested to distraction
with nautilus cups,
does everyone here know
what a nautilus cup is?
I mean, show of hands,
anyone not know what a?
So there, you've, I'm
sure you've seen one,
but I'm not sure it registered with you.
But there are these
renaissance objects made
from the shell of the chambered nautilus,
so that's this, you know, sea creature,
and it has that, that spiral shell,
but it's that large shell,
it's about this big,
and the shells would
be polished, you know,
so that you can, the outer,
the outer layer is taken off
to reveal the mother-of-pearl,
they're sometimes engraved,
but then they would be mounted
on these really elaborate kind
of, like stems, and braces,
to turn them into kind of,
you know, collectibles.
So I was interested in one, in particular,
that Walpole owned, and kept
in the great north bedchamber
at Strawberry Hill, it's
now in the Prinsenhof Museum
in Delft, although I think
there's a possibility
it may be coming to, it may be coming
to Yale next year for an exhibition.
So just a few words about
nautilus cups, just a few.
So the nautilus cup, in which the shell
of the chambered nautilus is mounted
in elaborately wrought
metal introduces problems
of scale, quite similar to
those Cindy illuminates
in "The Castle of Otranto," in
comparison to other seashells,
the nautilus is both
remarkable and valuable,
because it is giant, right,
it's a giant seashell.
But, as an object, especially one in the,
when it's made into the cup,
displaying ferocious monsters,
it's diminutive, so it's a way of,
like taking these, like, you know,
kind of like big
monsters, and putting them
into a shape that you can
put on a mantle, right.
And if we think about the
interior of the shell as a kind
of grotto, akin to the
space under the giant helmet
in which Theodore is
temporarily imprisoned,
it's a miniature, it's a miniature grotto.
In fact, I discovered, looking
at a particular nautilus cup
that was in The Louvre,
and I was so excited
when I saw this that I, I
actually cursed out loud
in the museum, it was very
embarrassing, 'cause it echoes.
But I saw it, I looked
in this nautilus shell,
and I discovered small
helms were routinely carved
in the interior of shells
prepared for nautilus cups,
so that when you peer into the chamber
of the mounted shell, what
faces you is a tiny helmet.
And I could say more about
why the artisan did this,
but I don't have time right
now, so you can ask me later.
Another thing I learned
about while researching
nautilus cups was the phenomenon
of catastrophic positive buoyancy,
which is something the chambered
nautilus can experience,
so that's the phrase that scientists use
to describe the fact the
chambered nautilus likes to be,
it's, like kind of a bottom dweller.
It likes to be deep in the water,
and it can propel itself up and down,
as well as around in the water,
but if it, for some
reason, rises too quickly
to the surface, it can't correct course
and propel itself back down,
and it dies on the surface,
so that's catastrophic positive buoyancy.
But this strikes me as
also a potential metaphor
for the feeling I associate
with the spectacle
of poor Conrad's violent
death by a ridiculous object.
Catastrophic positive buoyancy suggests,
to me, a form of hysterical laughter,
one out of control,
and triggered as easily
by calamity, disaster, and violence,
as by a good fortune,
one that is as likely
to feel painful in its
excess as pleasurable.
As a description of the
spirit that animates "Otranto,"
the phrase shows us how Walpole's sense
of humor is, in many ways, more indebted
to the excesses and
grotesqueries celebrated
in Greek satyr plays than to Roman satire.
In its more exuberant
moments, the gothic pushes us
to a giddy encounter with
the visceral material
of life and death in a way that seems,
by measures of classical
reasons, rather unhinged.
Ultimately, the funniness
of "The Castle of Otranto"
turns patriarchal emblems and institutions
into a suicidal killing joke.
Here, I'm still following
Cindy's lead, she writes,
"In 'Otranto,' it is almost as if,
"the bigger the phallus,
the bigger its impotence."
Which I think is true,
and this also leads me
to think back to Sandra's description
of the book as a "folly of ejaculation,"
maybe in a slightly different sense.
The stark and inflated hilarity
of phallic power rendered
impotent is central,
I would say, to the funniness
of Walpole's writing,
and it places him in a
genealogy of both intentionally,
and unintentionally funny English letters,
extending, at least in my project,
from Eliza Haywood to Thomas de Quincey.
But the failure implied
in scenes of impotence,
right, a failure to consolidate,
to embody, and to wield power,
is transformed by their funniness,
in scenes like these, into
a different kind of agency,
or, I would like to argue, a political,
a form of political promise.
Cindy concludes, in her reading,
that "'Otranto's' giant things
are meant to be a bit silly."
Pairing this observation with
Lauren Berlant's insistence
on the counter politics
of the silly object,
I've been trying to think
about both the cultural
and political stakes of
refusing to take the giants
of one's dominant social order seriously.
I'm thinking about how "Otranto"
reveals the clumsiness,
again, the clumsy, this
book is a clumsy thing,
the clumsiness and agitation
of patriarchal agents,
the scrambling, ineffectual male heroes,
but also the absurd helmet kind
of like tromping around the house,
of how it dares us, of
how the novel dares us not
to smirk at the gory revelation
of their embodied frailty,
those patriarchal agents,
and of the spectacular vulnerability
of patriarchal lineage on display
in Conrad's bleeding, mangled remains.
And of how the novel refuses
to provide the trappings
of patriarchal power and
inheritance with a dignified home,
offering only the
structurally unstable edifice
of a flagrantly fictional
paper castle that,
as Cindy points out, crumbles
at the slightest touch.
As a hero, Theodore is laughable,
the formal comedy that
should be consolidated
in his marriage to Isabella is transformed
by his feebleness as a vision of man
into a more satirical comedy,
centered on the catastrophic weakness
of patriarchy's privileged sons.
This is the catastrophic positive buoyancy
that interests me in "Otranto,"
opposite the nautilus,
whose positive buoyancy
carries it to catastrophe,
"Otranto's" catastrophes offer to lift us
by way of their hilarity to a place
where the death of particular institutions
of power takes on a festive
energy, and we are invited
to revel in the ruins of
their dignity, thank you.
(group applauds)
- I thank all the
speakers for the richness
of their papers, and the
brevity of their remarks,
which brings us out right
to pretty much on time
for a full discussion with
your questions leading us.
I will ask you to give
me a chance just to pause
after you ask your question
so that I can paraphrase it,
so that your question will be
picked up on the microphone,
and make the record coherent
when it is reviewed.
I open the floor.
- I would actually like
to see Sean diagram the
nautilus grotto. (laughs)
- I would like that, too, let's talk.
- John.
- (indistinct) Sean, something else
made me think that this notion of the papier-mache,
that, where it's covered with stucco,
and here's this part of the river,
Chiswick and Strawberry Hill, Pope's villa
close together, on the
tradition of the folly,
or the playful.
(background noise drowns out speaker) garden building
Which virtually always is fake,
it's not made of real stone, you know,
only when you get to the
rococo, with (indistinct).
you get a building that asserts its statements
And so, you know, I was
thinking about the papier-mache,
and the idea of Strawberry
Hill's being, I hope,
on your terms,
a kind of network description
of the gothic, not, not the gothic itself.
(background noise drowns out speaker)
Series of inscribed
statements, and condensations
about what the gothic is, a
little bit like his own book,
the, the book on English painting and art
01:05:10,787 --> 01:05:13,655
(background noise drowns out speaker)
Published before
"Otranto's", I just am trying
to put something out for people to,
to think about, that on Strawberry Hill,
I'm sure you all have been there,
I mean, it's small, it's manifestly fake,
I haven't seen the restoration,
but I assume that underlines the fakeness,
and in the dream, Cindy, one wonders
how the giant made it up
that papier-mache staircase.
(group laughs)
Which is so small, and
so fragile that the,
so I'm just trying to.
(background noise drowns out speaker)
- John Bender's question
is about the artifice
of the folly, and of the
papier-mache world created
around such a folly, and even
including the language is,
if I heard you right, of, the
descriptive language creating
that fairy tale castle in the mind.
I, was that directed particularly at Sean,
but anyone, yeah.
- What I heard in it,
that you were asking Sean,
was when you, when you called
what he was doing a kind
of description of the gothic,
rather than the gothic,
itself, right, your, your images as,
I guess in my term, an
ekphrasis of the gothic,
rather than, right, and so
that's what I would like
to hear you talk about,
because what I was struck by is
that each of you, of the rest of you,
were doing something that I didn't do,
which was to set up a kind of isomorphism
between these formal patterns
that you were registering,
although Jesse, that might
not be true, but like,
for you, Sean, there's an isomorphism
between this computer formalization
of cognitive processes,
right, and these architectural
forms, and then that leads
to a kind of claim, or a,
the stakes of that involve,
sort of, re-imagining the
moment of the 18th century
as a connectionist, rather
than a reductionist,
so that's functionalist, right.
And then in, you know,
for Cindy, there was
an isomorphism established
between these syntactic patterns
that you were noticing, and,
and I guess I ultimately
wrote down "genre," right,
so a certain sort of--
- And architectural.
- Yeah, as well as (indistinct),
and then, you know, for Eugenia,
there was this isomorphism,
and perhaps yours was
the strongest argument
that moved from this formal
isomorphism to a claim about,
in this case, politics, so
I was really struck by that,
that sort of, the
repetition of that structure
to the way we make arguments,
and so I just wanted
to sort of throw that out as
what I picked out from John's question.
A model of the sort they make in
architectural school
Rather than a building.
- I mean, I, I guess what I would,
I guess the question bears
on how deep we're willing
to allow the aesthetic to run, if it's,
I mean, the notion of, so I guess I would,
I would object to the, not object,
that's too strong, but I would object,
in a soft sense, I suppose, to the.
(group laughs)
To the, to the, to the notion of,
to the notion of
Strawberry Hill as a model.
I would unstrenuously
object to the notion of,
or strenuously, no, and instead, I mean,
I think of it, really, as
a residue to a process.
You know, one of the things we forget,
and I think, categorically forget
about Strawberry Hill is how
many times it was remodeled
and rebuilt, and it was often remodeled
and rebuilt not simply by Walpole himself,
but in consultation with other people,
and also with other people in mind,
like people he wanted to visit,
or people that he wanted
to have live there,
often other men, but not always other men.
And what's left now is,
of course, an object
that we tour, and it stands
as a kind of ornament book
of gothic style, but it
wasn't built that way,
right, it was built over time.
Some of the things I'm saying
here are relatively obvious,
but when I say that I
would experience it more
as a residue than as
a model, is that it's,
it's clearly a residue of a process
that unfolded over years,
over about 30 years,
that were also Walpole's most
productive literary years,
but not as a model in the
sense that it's something
that was ever held in
the mind whole, and then,
you know, and then projected in the way
that sometimes we think
of models as conceptual,
and also as material.
- Can I ask why you say "residue
of a process," rather than?
- Yeah.
- Well, I think a lot of the
joy of Strawberry Hill was,
you know, changing it, working with it,
you know, continually building,
that's why the papier-mache,
or the wallpaper, so, I
mean, if it's in stone,
it's in stone, but if it's wallpaper,
you could throw it up,
and see how it looks and,
unchanged, but, then, of
course, it's left over, right?
The thing is left there after
the remodeling has been done.
- I mean, he said that because he wants
for it not to be an object, right, Sean?
- Me?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, well, that's--
- Because to be an object is to be reduced
in some way, and you
want it to be an index
of a process, rather than--
- He wanted to have positive buoyancy--
- Which is why I think there's
an interesting connection
between the way you're
sort of producing this,
this sign of genre as
it's happening, right,
as it's sort of unfolding, Cindy,
and what, in this sort of, I think,
conceptual, or theoretical
investments of your argument,
Sean, in process, rather
than, say, objecthood or objectness.
- I just wanted to add to that,
to go back to John's
observation about the,
the ghost, right, like the giant,
the image of the giant ghost moving
through this very small, you know, house.
I think that, that the
way that bodies move
through the actual house
of Strawberry Hill is also
something that the
space is doing, I don't,
I don't know that it was
designed, exactly, right,
it wasn't like, modeled so that, you know,
bodies would move in
a particular way, but.
And this is something
that I had never thought
about until I actually
found myself in the space,
'cause you kind of have to be in it
to realize the proportions of it,
like the proportions are
off from what you're led
to imagine you would
feel from images of it,
and I think that's part
of what it's doing,
but this was, this was
brought home pretty starkly,
the first time that I went,
so this is like in fall, 2014,
and it was the first time that I'd gone
after the restoration, and the docent
that was kind of showing me around,
originally, took me up the staircase,
and on the banisters, they had these,
you know, beautiful little deer ornaments
that, it refers to the family
seal, or, you know, something,
and on the second floor, one
of them was missing, and, like,
it, like it looked like
it had just been torn off.
And the docent apologized
that it was such a mess,
and they hadn't, you
know, like cleaned it up,
or, like, you know, repaired it.
But he said, just the day or two before,
someone had come in with a giant backpack,
and as they rounded the corner,
they just knocked the deer
right off the banister.
But that's kind of what it's like
to move around in that space,
so just being like a
normal-sized human being,
or maybe like a slightly
larger, you know, than normal,
you feel, you feel the odd proportions
of your body in relation
to the space around you.
- Can I say one more
thing about the artifice?
And that is that, I mean, it's important
for us to acknowledge that, I mean,
the very term "gothic," I mean,
it's referring explicitly to a typeface,
I mean, it's referring explicitly
to its status as print.
And Cindy, actually, when you were,
you know, giving your presentation,
one of the most absurd lines to me is,
when Theodore, we have,
"He printed 1,000 kisses
"on her clay cold hands,
and uttered every expression
"that despairing love could dictate."
I asked my undergraduates,
can you imagine printing,
you know, that many number of kisses?
And, you know, part of, I think,
that, the absurdity comes
through the recognition
that we're dealing with printed words,
you know, here on a page, and so,
you know, I think there's
a strong attention
to drawing our attention
to the, the status
of objects as codes for something.
And, you know, the clock
is a code for something,
it signals time, but the
conception of time is really kind
of matter, you know,
modeled on the movement
of the clock, circularly, rather than
what it actually implies.
(background noise drowns out speaker)
- Architectural models as working objects,
but there's attention in
Walpole's own behavior between
that fragility, on one hand, and his wish
to render the building permanent
in the book he published,
showing these rooms, you
know, so there's a, there's a,
and that book projects
them, to go to your point.
The rooms don't really look like that,
the rooms in the engravings
look much more monumental
and significant than they
look in the actual building.
- The extra illustrations
in that book play into
that, as well, process,
not residue, exactly,
but ongoing, interpenetrative,
and upsetting,
or readjusting the perspectives
with every addition.
- Ruth?
- This is not so much a
question, as a comment,
but I was struck, Eugenia,
in your description
of moving around the building,
and the knocked-off deer thing,
it seems like, it read like a reversal
of what the novel does, right,
in which making these huge objects,
knocking down, destroying
the fragile people,
and, you know, I wonder
if that isn't the kind of,
you know, the part of the
gap between the small,
the small actual staircase,
and the (indistinct)
new staircases, and doing that kind
of flipping around, I mean--
- Yeah.
- But it seems so, you
know, it seems so close to.
(background noise drowns out speaker)
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Professor Yeazell has
inverted the relationship
of backpack to helmet.
(group laughs)
(overlapping chatter)
- Brilliant.
- Well, I wanted just
to follow up on this,
on this wonderful discussion, in part by,
I think, maybe, continuing along
what Sandra introduced, of how
(background noise drowns out speaker) one's encountered
The gothic structure
provides a kind of allegory
for the way that one reads the novel,
and, and maybe to see if we can just bring
that out a bit, and I want for us to,
maybe for us to think, alongside
the Strawberry Hill as a model,
there's, of course, "The
Castle of Otranto" itself
as a model, and there we actually,
as Sandra pointed out, we
don't really quite know
what it looks like, but
one thing that we do know,
and this maybe, this is a
question for the whole panel,
but I'll begin with Sean, in this respect,
is that we do know that
it's kind of (indistinct).
In a sense that the helmet is not buoyant,
in fact, it cracks a
hole, and that hole allows
for the moonlight to go
and shine on the people,
and then to illuminate
the passage that's below.
So it's like surface, and
then there's an interior,
and below the interior there's a passage,
all of which provide an account
of death, you know, whether or not
that's the functional
and computational model
that you offered, it might be one
that's completely (indistinct),
which seems like a kind
of model of the monument of unconscious,
but in any case, it's a, a, it's not,
it doesn't seem to me like a flat neural net,
connectionist, you know, emergent process
that your were describing,
but it's one that's sort
of really much more
hermeneutic in its structure.
So that, using that term,
I think I'm suggesting the
(indistinct) of allegories
for the way in which we read
it, (indistinct), you know,
descriptive paraphrase
on the model of like
what Sandra was saying,
or whether or not we're
actually doing something like
interpretation. (indistinct)
- Yeah, no, I--
(overlapping chatter)
- Jonathan Kramnick has asked a question
about the nature of the
castle, Strawberry Hill,
as an architectural edifice,
and the castle in the novel,
as an allegory of reading for the text.
- Yeah, no, that's good,
Jonathan, thanks for that.
I mean, I'll say two things,
one's mildly technical,
as I understand it, which is that,
I mean, this is an old objection
to the neural net model,
is that it would presumably be incapable
of having higher order
representations of itself,
and this is Jerry
Fodor's objection to the.
But it, but that's, I mean,
that's actually been
empirically disproven,
that there have been neural networks
that return descriptions of themselves.
So that's a, in the
sense that that kind of,
like higher order, lower
order, the sort of,
that structural distinction that we seem
to detect in human
cognition between higher
and lower order processes,
that that can be simulated
by a neural network in the same way
that a neural network could be simulated
by a functionalist system, but the.
Yeah, the other thing
that I wanted to say,
this really, I guess, goes
back to my earlier work
on thinking about Walpole, thinking
about "The Castle of Otranto,"
and especially about,
you know, his other
great gothic experiment,
"The Mysterious Mother," is the extent
to which, the illusions of
interiority that emerge,
or the effects of interiority, I'm talking
about human psychic interiority,
emerge in a complex, cognitive ecology of,
kind of a dialogue, or
an elaborated dialogue
of relationship between
persons and spaces.
Right, so that, that's, I mean,
that would be, I guess, in a way my,
what do we call it, fallback position?
Or where I draw my line in the sand is,
is that there's, Walpole
doesn't seem to me,
at least, to be sketching out a model,
which I, in some ways actually argue
for in the last, in the last book,
and which I'm now
starting to argue against,
of a strict kind of a,
what we might almost call
a quasi-dualist model of
the, you know, of conscious,
and then, you know,
subconscious interiority,
but instead elaborates that in these, in,
in these ecological relationships
with person and place.
- I'd like to elaborate on that, too,
on Jonathan's point about
depth being interpretive,
not just psychological, but generic,
and part of the reading process.
That passage, where I pointed out
that Manfred leaves, and comes back,
and we have that little textual space
of other time, other place, it's something
that the gothic develops especially well,
kind of pulling apart time and space.
Think of "The Monk," when Ambrosio sinks on,
into Matilda's arms, "I am thine,"
and 15 minutes later, and
130 pages later, (laughs)
he pops back up in a different
volume, and it's over.
And there are so many
textual, subterranean passages
that way that, you know,
other novels make use of,
too, but I really think
that's one of the kind
of architectural
innovations of the gothic.
- I'd like to build on that, and I think,
possibly, also respond
to Ruth's observation
about the, the physical vulnerability
of the built environment,
in relation to the,
the bodies that move, the human
bodies that move through it.
But I think that, I
think one of the things
that's funny, to me, at least,
about the gothic ruins, like the castle,
in "The Castle of Otranto," has to do
with the way that the
novel is playing with time,
and in another way, and the
relationship between time
and ruination, like historical
processes of ruination,
because one of the things that the gothic,
this gothic story is doing,
is it ruins things instantaneously, right?
So it's like you think of
the gothic ruin as something
that has been ruined over
some extended period of time,
and therefore, you know,
speaks to historical time,
in a particular way is, like evidence
of the way material
doesn't last, you know,
when you think about time
in a big picture way.
But, but what's happening
to, just, for example,
like the castle here, is
it's just being destroyed,
right before our eyes, it's
being ruined immediately.
And so, I think that, I think
that that's something that,
I think this was kind of
like an ongoing project
of Walpole's, in a certain way,
I think he was interested
in what happens when you,
like, what you make
when you ruin something.
And so that's, that's one of the things
that I think the castle is, he's doing
with the castle in the story.
The frontispiece is a (indistinct) portrait.
Yeah, that's, yeah, is there,
I'm seeing if I've got a
picture of that in my edition.
- Yes?
- I have a question for Sandra.
I love the idea that the novel
is thin and flat (indistinct)
And I gather--
- Thin and dead, I think.
- Well, I gather from your reading
that one of the things that (indistinct),
would involve is
this kind of anthropomorphism,
or, I'm sorry,
isomorphism that--
- Right.
- That we're talking about here.
- I mean, I said I
ventriloquized a couple.
- Yeah.
- Ways you could do that, but I--
- In more, even coming
out, right, an allegory--
- Yes, exactly, yeah, yeah.
- So I guess I just
want to hear you respond
to these kind of
isomorphisms, what's at stake
in resistance in your resistance, but also,
what's at stake in the
way the novel is seeming
to invite them in--
- Oh, I mean, I, I'm totally persuaded
by each of these absolutely
virtuosic allegorical readings
of form, totally, I love
it, I do, I mean, come on.
I do that, we all do that when we teach,
you know, I just did it
with my undergraduates,
you know, we talked about interruption,
this inability to follow whose speaking,
right, as a sort of, you know, objective,
correlative for the
thematics of usurpation,
et cetera, et cetera, I could do it,
and I, and I think, you know,
and I'm powerfully persuaded
by these sorts of
arguments, I just was trying
to think about what it would look like
to resist doing it, whether
we can resist doing it,
either just in a, like
in a sort of banal way.
You know, whether reading
is always, I mean,
in a sense, it is always comprehension,
you know, we're not reading
just morphemes, right?
We're always reading
at the syntactic level,
and therefore, at the level of meaning,
and so, you know, so there's that,
and then there's also just this sort of
disciplinary
force of that move from form to meaning.
And so, really, I'm just
being, I don't know,
perverse is maybe, I just,
I'm just really curious,
as a kind of intellectual, theoretical,
you know, endeavor, game, I
don't, just, what it, what,
you know, what it, what would
happen if you didn't do that?
And then maybe all that
happens is a kind of lame,
like deixis, right, where,
you know, it's like,
look, look at all these
exclamation points, cool.
(group laughs)
You know?
- One alternative, or
something that might happen,
like the desire for
description that Heather Love
provides an account of therefore you
don't interpret as described.
- Well, yeah, but she doesn't do that.
She doesn't do it. Right, right, right.
- Could it be that this fulfills
the Lovean remit, just saying that
exclamation points, check it out.
- But I'm not sure I even did,
I'm not sure I even did that,
because it's embarrass, I mean.
(group laughs)
It's so unscholarly to do that.
- Well, I guess I wanted
a little more elaboration,
'cause I don't quite get it,
I guess I feel fundamentally
aesthetic design,
down to the ground, but--
- Oh, that, I would say that this,
that if we say that The
Castle of Otranto is a game
in which the entire 100
pages is a literalization
of the phrase, "grown
too large to inhabit it,"
I'm not saying it's not designed.
- I guess what I, (indistinct)
was what's the difference
in the, in the kind of suggested reading,
or non-interpretive description
that's pre-critical, versus post-critical?
- Um, well, you know,
the post-critique stuff
often reproduces the descriptive turns,
turn to eros, or ethos, as, you know,
the alternative to
hermeneutics, or something.
Or, it's, sometimes the form it takes is
an interest in phenomenology
of reading, or, and,
so what that says, to me,
is that whatever is being longed for,
or described in these
theoretical positions,
it's not actually being fulfilled,
that the desire is not actually a desire
for literality, because there
has to be something more
at stake in what we do than that,
and it has to be called
"ethics," or "politics,"
or the eros of art, or whatever, right?
So, I think I'm mostly just interested
in the theoretical project, and kind
of like pushing back against,
not against the drive
for pure description,
but against the idea that, that,
that that's actually what
people who are calling
for the turn are
doing, and then maybe,
maybe then to say, maybe
they're not doing it
because we can't do it, but
I think they're not doing it
because in Heather Love's
case, she cannot abide the idea
of not giving a political
account of "Beloved,"
that is intolerable to us,
c.f. my forthcoming essay
called "The Political Fallacy."
- Wait, can I ask a followup question,
though, of Sandra, is
that alright, about this?
I wonder if, like this is
such an earnest question,
I want to know what you think.
Is Walpole's "Description
of the Villa" doing
to his house what an actual
descriptive reading would do
to the text, would do to the novel?
That is, like the "Description
of the Villa" is this,
I mean, I find it this
incredibly puzzling text.
I've tried really hard to use it,
you know, to make use of it, but it's,
but it's just a catalog,
I mean, that's all,
that's what it is, it's just a catalog,
and, so there's a part of
me that's like, well I,
you know, I'm good at reading,
I'm good at interpreting,
I can interpret a catalog.
There's actually something about it
that stymies interpretation, you know,
you kind of find yourself, you're just,
you're just reading a stark list,
with very little, every once in awhile,
there's a little bit of
contextual information,
but very little, and so if you
read it from cover to cover,
what you've done is just
taken this descriptive view,
room by room, of all the spaces
in a way that doesn't leave
you with anything, really.
I mean, I guess you have some knowledge
of what was there, you know, what kind
of objects were there,
but, is that the kind of--
- I mean, I'm really interested in that,
that form, actually, and so I,
so this week, we read
"Roderick Random," and I'm, I,
in doing research on the
novel, I came across this essay
from, like 1979 by a linguist, who's like,
"Literary critics don't have
any respect for us linguists,
"us, like serious, scientific,
structural linguists.
"And so everyone talks
about Smollett's style,
"but nobody ever says
how his style works."
So this guy goes ahead and gives this,
you know, morphology,
linguistic morphology
of the structure of Smollett's sentences,
and then goes on to show,
like how this structure is repeated,
and it's, so it's like,
you know, I don't know,
subordinate clause, plus verb, you know,
I mean, I, I can't do it, myself.
But I, so I was like, "So, kids,
"folks, what do we, you
know, what do we, like,"
they're supposed to write,
like ekphrases this week
of something, they can either write,
you know, doing, a verbal
ekphrasis of an object,
they can do, you know,
they can, I don't care,
like 3D print an object that's like,
you know, a reading of
"The Castle of Otranto."
So I was like, you know, what, is this
what we should be doing, is this
what the fulfillment
of Heather Love's call
for description would look like?
And we sort of decided, well, A,
we don't know how to do
that, we're not trained
to do that,
but, you know, I forget what B was, but.
(group laughs)
(overlapping chatter)
But yeah, I'm interested in what happened
to morphological sort of thinking
after structuralism, and, you know,
it seems to me like this
return to formalism,
it, it is not, weirdly, a
return to structuralism,
or even some aspects
of post-structuralism,
whereas you would think
that a true commitment
to pure description would look a lot more
like structural linguistics,
than like anything else,
but we don't want that, I
don't think we want that.
I mean, I might, but I don't think,
you know, Heather Love does.
- Yes?
- I just had a brief
followup to that (indistinct),
I really enjoyed your description
of Bianca's failed simile, so the,
that's kind of the (indistinct),
because it strikes me
that another way of thinking about this,
like failure of interpretation,
or this (indistinct)
interpretation the sublime,
so like, you, Bianca,
like looks at the helmet,
and can't describe it,
because that's part of,
that's part of like the failure,
the sublime being a kind of
failure of representation.
And so then, the failure,
that kind of funniness,
potentially, of "Castle of Otranto" being
part of the failure of the sublime.
So I was just wondering if there's a way
to kind of link those two.
- Well, but Bianca can't, it's not
that Bianca can't describe it, she,
I mean, you could say she
can't, she also won't.
I mean, it comes at the
end of that whole encounter
with Manfred, where she's
continually using language
in a way to, you know, so she's
continually picking up sort
of literal syntax as a way of resisting
what Manfred wants to know, which is,
where is Isabella, or, you know, what,
what does Isabella feel about
Theodore or whatever, right?
So, it's a strategy, or at
least it comes at the end
of a passage, or an
exchange, that's very much
about a strategic use of indexicality,
or a sort of refusal of, you know, to,
to represent, that is not a kind
of ontological failure,
epistemological failure, but a strategy.
So that's my (indistinct), and it's funny,
you know, it's part of
the wit of that moment,
is Bianca is this sort
of wily servant figure,
her, you know, her, I don't
know, I don't know what it,
like indirection of speech, right?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yes?
- I have what I think
is a followup question.
When you're talking, you
made me think of this,
this is kind of as an aside,
Adorno has this line
somewhere where he says,
"The literal is the barbaric,"
and you were making me think, the literal,
which may be the gothic, and, you know,
that's a roundabout way of
asking about the relationship
between aesthetics and cognition,
'cause that seems like it's
in the background here.
(background noise drowns out speaker)
Fairly descriptive
literal reading would in,
in some ways be to engage in a kind
of non-cognitive aesthetics, or something,
or at least the fear of that?
(background noise drowns out speaker)
Interpretation is the
kind of, like buzzword
that becomes a site of
contestation between these two,
modes of reading it, I guess, this
is kind of long-winded,
and maybe trailing off prematurely,
but I wondered if, like there's a,
an option besides the two we kind of,
he kind of sketched in response to.
(background noise drowns out speaker)
Interpretation, or a
resistance of interpretation,
maybe there's something like, you know,
interpretation whose goal
is to get beyond itself,
you know, interpretation might,
like exhaust its
possibilities through sort
of like similes that don't simulate,
that don't get it right.
I don't know how this works,
particularly in relation
to "The Castle of Otranto,"
but I think it's an argument
that Paul Fry says
arrives with romanticism,
but maybe, on your reading,
it arrives with the gothic.
Yeah.
- Part of this question
is about the relation
of aesthetics and cognition
in interpretation.
- I mean, Sean, what do you
think of this idea that,
that a literal
criticism raises the specter
of a non-cognitive aesthetic?
That's what I heard you say, initially.
- Yes, it's an interesting question, and.
In a sense it cuts to
the core of what it is
that we think we do when we're thinking,
whether we think that we're fundamentally
about association, or
whether we think we're
about storage and
processing, I'm thinking,
I'm still thinking about
Walpole's relationship
to description, and, as Gena pointed out,
the, his most descriptive text, his,
the "Description
of the Villa," which was remodeled,
you know, published twice,
and it's different in each.
But that it's, it's sustaining,
my sense is that it works, if you read it,
and you're not satisfied.
- Right, right.
- And that that's why there's a ticket
to go visit the house that's included.
- Yeah.
- Because that "Description" has a,
inasmuch as it's a human document,
I mean, inasmuch as it's
an informational document,
you know, art historians can use it
to establish provenance, it could be,
it's, it is, of Walpole's documents,
it is the one that could
most easily be converted
into a database, I think, you know?
- Yeah.
- These are the things that he
had, here's where they were.
But, but it's also the document that most,
maybe not most, but for
effect, let's say most,
relies on the space that it imagines,
in that, that in fact,
it draws you to the space
that it imagines, which
is to say that it's,
it's in a, a kind of
intense dialogue with,
an associative dialogue,
I think, with the,
with the house that it records.
So, yeah, I guess would say that--
- Would you call it poiesis?
This listing of what's there--
- I think you might call
it, I, no, I wouldn't.
(group laughs)
That's what I would ask you
what you would call it.
- Could it, I mean, it's non-narrative,
but it is a narrative of space.
- And a movement through it.
- Yeah, I mean, that's,
yeah, just to be clear,
I mean, that's the other
thing that it's been quite,
it's been pretty rigorously established
that it wasn't designed
as an auction catalog
so much as it was designed as a hand list
for a tour that you weren't taking yet.
- But it also sets up, I mean, I think,
this is kind of a speculative statement,
but I think it also sets
up a certain encounter
with the objects, once you
actually take your ticket
and go there, that itself is
designed to be unsatisfying.
Like, I think that, I mean, just,
just kind of based on
my own experience of,
you, having read this "Description,"
become very enamored of the idea
of getting a better
experience with these objects,
right, like this "Description"
is telling me a little bit,
but what it's really telling me is
that I don't really
know what this thing is,
I would understand it better if I saw it,
you know, in actual space, ideally,
if I saw it in Strawberry Hill, right,
and I know there's been,
like all of these attempts
to get the objects back into the house,
so people can have that experience.
But, but then, you know,
you come to the object,
and, I don't, I mean, I'm saying
this as a literary scholar
who's been trying to, like
work with material objects,
or read material objects,
like you get there,
and you're in front of
it, and you're like,
that's cool, it's a little bit
like the exclamation points,
right, it's like, that's cool,
but I'm not having some kind
of revelatory experience unlocked simply
by having come into contact with it,
so it's, it's like it
begins a narrative of,
of continual unsatisfying
contact with, with the object.
- You know, I was just
thinking, as you said this,
one of the, we read Virginia Woolf in our,
my graduate class, and
the essays that Mrs.
- Bennett and, right.
- Mrs. Brown, where she
talks about the experience
of reading a lot of 18th century text,
"Tristram Shandy" and "Pride and Prejudice,"
as completely satisfying,
when you're done,
all you want to do is pick it up,
read it again, understand it better,
unlike her, the late 19th century,
and her contemporaries.
But I wonder, I mean, we've been talking
about the gothic
architecturally and literarily
as unsatisfying, with that
fall out of that kind of,
and does that Woolfian criticism
even play a part in your,
in sort of finding a middle ground,
and interpretively, in any sense?
Does that make any sense?
- Just very quickly, I think, I mean,
the other, it's Walpole's
other gothic experiment,
I think, the, you know,
"The Mysterious Mother,"
that is his argument
about the relationship
between desire, and the object, and it,
as a play that was famously
published, but that,
famously publicized,
but withheld from view,
and that the house, again, reenacts that,
as a play that you can,
you can never quite see,
it's announced in the catalog,
but you're not allowed to read it.
- And the Beauclerk closet, too,
like that one kind of secretive space.
And the drawings no longer exist, right,
I mean, even when you
go visit the house now,
they'll tell you, "This
is the Beauclerk closet
"where the drawings of "The
Mysterious Mother" were displayed
"for Walpole's own private enjoyment,"
but I think those drawings
are non-existent, right?
- They're here.
- Oh, no--
- Six or seven of them, I think.
- Oh, okay, sorry, I'm completely,
I'm completely wrong then, but anyway,
there is this kind of, (laughs)
this is this setup of revelation--
- And the manuscript for the play was kept
in a cabinet there, too.
- Okay.
- Yeah, but there's the famous,
there's several encounters of people
with those drawings, after
having read about them,
these celebrated drawings,
and there's a marvelous note
in one of the auction catalogs, when,
when they were finally seen,
and he just simply says,
"They're actually rather ordinary,
"and out of context, there's
nothing to recommend them."
- Right, right.
- Yes, Sarah?
- So I was just thinking
about this question,
about whether there's a third way
of reading between description
and interpretation,
and I was wondering if phenomenology,
or a phenomenological
account of reading is,
is not, our answer to
what that third way is,
because when you, to get, to
read in a phenomenological way,
as I take it, is to give a report
of the encounter with the text,
which is not the same
as giving a description,
because it's not pretending
that it's not filtered
through a consciousness, and, you know,
I was just trying to think about all,
what is it that I'm trying to do
when I write about "The Castle of Otranto,"
or any other text, and I was
thinking, it's something,
like well, what I think
I'm doing is asking myself
how it's asking to be interpreted.
And, of course, you could say,
well that's, you know,
that's, whatever your answer
to that question is is
itself an interpretation,
but I feel like the, the
phenomenological answer would
be the in telling you how
I think this text is asking
to be interpreted, that is my account of
what it is like to encounter
this text, and to say
that it is offering up these
different possibilities,
these different ways of
reading it, and the, my job,
as the critic, is to articulate those,
and make them explicit in some way.
So, I don't, I just was wondering
if phenomenology is a helpful way
of thinking about a third term,
in addition to interpretation
and description?
- Yeah, the question
is about phenomenology
as an alternative to the descriptive,
or the interpretive methods.
- Can I say something,
Sandra, I know this is kind
of directed to you, but, I mean, for me,
this is, I mean, it's really kind of one
of Walpole's most lasting legacies,
and we get that in the first
preface, is that, you know,
I wish this novel had more
of a moral than that the sins
of future generations
would be visited upon you,
it's kind of a open avowal
of kind of, you know,
the content-less, or the, you, the,
our foolishness in
attempting to, you know,
begin to ask interpretive questions of it,
I mean, it seems to me that, you know,
he's, he's very canny, or aware, and,
you know, seeking to promote
a different kind of reading,
probably than, you know,
the realist tradition
of the novel, but, you know, certainly,
you know, I think it's a, you know,
it's a, a different way of
looking at art, I think.
- Going off of that, do you see the sort
of (indistinct) and intersubjective realism
of a text like "Mrs.
Dalloway" as a different kind
of fantasia of the realization?
- Mm-hmm.
Yeah, well, I mean, it's an open question,
I mean, this is certainly, you know,
one of the, you know, key texts of,
you know, I would describe
of modernist realism,
in that, you know, the depiction of the,
you know, the consciousness, you know,
such that we have never seen, I think,
in literature, but, I mean, I
think that it's also important
to recognize, just to
contradict what I just said,
that, I mean, there's,
there's extraordinary realism
in "The Castle of Otranto," in that sort of,
you know, obsessional looking
for character motivations.
And, you know, John
Bender, sitting over there,
is, you know, I think the kind of pioneer
in recognizing, you know, this work as,
you know, offering free
and direct discourse,
really, at a capacity you never see.
And, you know, if we can describe free
and direct discourse as
an important feature of,
you know, modern narrative realism,
you know, it is there in this
work that declares itself
to be morally content-less.
- I mean, I wouldn't, I, myself,
wouldn't be entirely comfortable
with the distinction between
realism and the gothic,
gothicism and realism, but,
and nor would I associate realism
with the adumbration of consciousness.
So,
I guess I'm sort of, I actually take a lot
of what I was saying about
literalism as an account
of its real, of realism,
and, and for me,
the, you know, the way
that that literalism,
for Walpole, is a kind of, is an interest
in, I guess what I'm trying to,
sort of thinking of as emblematics,
sort of, an, you know, an
emblematics of the primary,
the primary qualities of, or
attributes of certain forms,
as, you know, sort of how realism works.
Doors, casements, stairs,
male bodies, female bodies,
right, it, it doesn't, when
the human figure emerges,
it doesn't seem, to me,
substantively different
from the way doors work in, in the novel.
So that, you know, that's,
I guess what, and so,
oh, and as for "Mrs. Dalloway,"
I actually have started
to think of that novel,
in particular, as a,
a kind of apotheosis of a
literalism so extreme as
to be, as a kind of hyper-materiality,
so that, like Woolf's
aesthetic is so much,
it's like Mondrian, it's
like colors, shape, line,
you know, and that's
what interests me more,
I guess, these days, than
about, about "Mrs. Dalloway,"
than, than consciousness.
- We have time for one more
question in this session.
Yes?
- I have a question about
funniness as it relates
to two, I guess sort of adjacent,
or potentially overlapping categories,
which would be, I guess the
genre of comedy, and bathos,
and I was wondering about, just the,
and I guess, also this connects to,
to your question about the sort of,
the potential for inversion
in the relationship
between the body and the space,
so that it could be sort of, I don't know,
a joke on the body, that, as sort
of perceiving the clumsiness
of one's own body in a space,
or either the objects or the body start
to think kind of funny or off.
And this would, I mean, I, I'm curious
what you would think about this,
but it seems like one thing
that distinguishes the
funny would be that kind
of instability about like,
what, what is the target
of the joke, or the target of the satire?
And that made me also
wonder about the status
of the two prefaces in
relation to one another,
and that sort of performance of,
in the editorial history of a kind of joke
on the reader, and what would that do
to the sort of, the target of the,
the sort of imminent target of the,
of the joke of the book,
which you're suggesting might be sort
of, like patriarchal,
institutional structure of,
like, does that sort of,
re-filtering of that adjust
that meeting in any way, or ask us to?
- Right, yeah.
- The question is, if it's
funny, what's the joke?
(group laughs)
- Right, yeah, yeah, and that's,
that's actually a brilliant
way of distilling that,
'cause I think that what I've,
what I've come to
understand, more and more,
as I've been working on this project,
is that I'm less
interested in the funniness
of jokes than I am in
instances of
funniness arriving from an instability of,
of maybe we could say,
like relative positions,
I mean, I'm thinking now about, you know,
Sean's work on relationships.
And so, I mean, I'm thinking a little bit
about your question about the prefaces,
but it, but it made me
leap to something else,
which is what I'm going to
actually talk about. (laughs)
Maybe there's an answer to
your question here somewhere.
But one of the, like one
of the kinds of funniness
that I have come to think
about more and more is the way
that 18th century texts,
like "The Castle of Otranto,"
are funny to contemporary readers,
like how they're funny
to us, and funny in a way
that they're not, that they're
almost certainly not designed
to be, right, so there's
no reason to think
that when Walpole was writing this,
that one of the things he
had anywhere in his mind was,
what is this, how is this going to read
to a 21st century reader, (laughs) right?
But there is, there is a
certain, like very palpable kind
of funniness to 18th century prose,
and I think the texture of the prose
that Cindy was talking
about is a large part of it.
When students, for example,
like when we teach these texts,
and students read it for the first time,
they frequently, like, they'll say, like,
"I don't get it," or, "I don't
understand what's going on."
But they're still compelled
through something like curiosity
that I think that, that's even heightened,
sometimes, into thinking it's funny,
what they're looking at is funny.
And it doesn't mean they
feel like there's a joke
that they're in on there, it
just means there's something,
like, I'm trying to put my, I'm trying
to come up with a way of describing what
that something is that they're picking up,
when they say, "Yeah,
this was really funny,"
I didn't, you know, like what.
And then the followup
question is, like what,
what is going on, right, what's happening?
But I think that that is, is coming out
of the instability of the
relationship between reader
and text, and particularly,
like, you know,
reader, in her own moment in history,
and text, kind of like speaking
from its moment in history,
and so, so yeah, like, Walpole,
so to go back to my point about the way
that Walpole is playing
with instantaneous ruins,
I almost feel a little bit
like his multiple prefaces are,
like speeding up that
process of a text kind
of revealing itself as a
different text through time,
through one edition to the next, right?
It kind of radically reframes the text
in a way that we might see,
as literary historians,
or we might interpret as happening,
like in this kind of organic way,
just because the world
changes through time,
and so the things in it change, as well.
But I think that Walpole
is kind of saying,
like, no, I mean, maybe, but also,
we can do this, and
generate those effects kind
of immediately in the here and now.
- I'm not going to end
the conversation here,
but pause it, with the note that one
of the pleasures, or
among the many pleasures
of a Country House Weekend,
not shooting birds,
not chasing foxes, but
carrying on the conversation
into the next session, so tally ho.
(group applauds)